need a new clock sampler 201 that same
day welcome back today we are going to
do life fails now if you are an avid
modern wisdom listener you all know that
we often do a life hacks series it's one
of our most popular and today we are
going to give our best stories about
when those those journeys into making
our life more optimal go awry and I
think is the best we need a broad area
yeah I'm death by optimization not one
of these slow do not fat ego can go
directly to being beheaded I think we
need to let you open up with your first
life in yourself as that list
Chris and I probably have like a couple
between us yeah I think I've got
sentiment and you've got more life fails
than you do life hacks I think a lot of
my fails stuff that you to remind me
over there yeah oh yeah what about that
yeah I don't know why they seem tighter
than this yeah it's just my favorite
list Johnny wants to see the little like
so are we doing the underwater judgment
so I think I think that the first one
that you should do is Jasmine pool why
you got banned from the pool in town
okay
so early on in my quest released esteem
no a stick from Meadows it's right it's
going
yeah come on okay we can get to that one
for sure Oh any requests and everything
so in early on in my quest for
optimization I read a book that
described a process that supposedly
Albert Einstein used I think that's one
of those most overused things and then
just say oh this is the thing that
Albert Einstein did it just instantly
give something credibility a technique
called image streaming and this is where
supposedly you strengthen the
connections with the corpus callosum
between the right and left brain to
create more connections and to
communicate the left brain and so that
involves like a series of lying down
with the tape recorder and just
describing verbally the things that you
see and not bring them into awareness
idea started me off and Endon ended up
with me being kicked out with jasmine -
what happened was along with the image
streaming I ended up searching more of
it and there was a combined method that
someone recommended which is submersion
in water for one hour a day total time
so total cumulative time of an hour a
day for three weeks and the idea is by
doing that you create an adaptation in
your body where you increase the surface
area of your carotid arteries the
arteries that supply the brain and
increase the blood flow to the brain
equating to supposedly like a ten-point
increase in IQ so I read that and
without any further verification as I
write in a triad so went into the pool
in in one town and basically how about a
digital watch stop by the side of the
ladder thing and just push myself
underwater and time
myself and just built up as you do 30
seconds on 30 seconds on yeah well like
60 60 on 60 off oh so it would take two
hours in the proofing there's two hours
a day in the pool for three weeks first
two days lifeguard caught wind of this
guy doing stuff he was awesome dude yeah
but I'm trying to increase this right so
he kicked me out wasn't allowed to go
back ended up going to another pool
where I was able to continue the journey
there is actually a side story to the
first one which I was I was basically
scared for I was there was the most
scared I've ever been in my life I got a
little permanent marker I was I was like
16 at the time a permanent marker and I
quite liked the idea of writing Arabic
text I thought it looks quite cool so I
did that in the changing rooms in this
pool and then the next day I turned up
and there was police vans outside and
they closed the pool and I was like oh
God I drove to the conclusion of they've
seen the Arabic they think the terrorist
attack is incoming what did you write
just like it just something innocuous
but I was like they they've seen it they
think there's someone's planted a bomb
of the they've closed off the pool
they're gonna see me on the CCTV like
that's the rest of my life done and I
just you know you jump to the worst
conclusion all right I'm gonna be
arrested as a terrorist and thus but you
didn't - the man you managed to complete
the rest of your breathing and is it
different did he work no I didn't test
it which was the first step but yeah
there was another guy I know who did
something similar where he edged so he
took himself to the point of proof just
about to ejaculate and then came back
and did that to himself every day for a
month didn't have sex with his
girlfriend the whole time which must
have been really annoying for her
because he thought it would increase his
testosterone
so there is for a month night I'm sorry
now can't have sex with you because I'm
doing my thing optimize my testosterone
and what happened again I was like did
you retraining at the time did you
measure anything no calories were no
right about day one of months two was
fun that cut himself across the room who
feel like you've been naughty
yeah when you spend a month trading
yourself to not do that bit yeah and
then I did it right Johnny what have you
got it all just flies in just some
rubbish compared to that I had a
experience at uni where I was just
learning about alcohol metabolism and
how to best basically I was on a quest
for how can I get as drunk as I want to
get without experiencing a hangover and
any negative fatless consequences
whatsoever so ate only like protein
fluff all day which is nice but like
there's not very much sustenance thing
gets to 7:00 p.m. and I've devised this
situation where I have everyone at eye
level with so six people all doing this
we played Centurion but with vodka and
the idea was in about an hour or less
we'd have all the alcohol we're gonna
have for the rest of the evening
give it plenty of time to clear so by
time we woke up would be near sober yeah
of six people run load the alcohol that
extreme off six people tea people made
it out the house one person was
borderline alcohol poisoning and passed
out and me and the person who made it
out were end up loosing
things we regret it so what you're
saying is don't try okay so let's just
drink normally yep just true normally
there is no way to optimizer unfortunate
so my 23rd birthday I'd organised to go
and buy a car on my birthday but then
went out with
my business partner Darrin to go and see
Skrillex in digital and as I did at the
time the exact reason why I'm sober now
I'm an all-or-nothing kind of guy when
it comes to drinking and ended up I
remember downing about half of the litre
of Grey Goose in about three minutes
from a speed poorest rate arming it into
my mouth later on in the evening I
dislocated my knee in the mosh pit
popped it back in Darren he popped it
back in yourself
yeah Darren got me on his back cuz I
could no longer walk both due to the
alcohol and you the fact of pot money
bucket Darren piggyback he didn't take
any often or was that the first time it
ever happened never happened
I'm speechless by that Chris how did you
happen to piles it was a letter but you
saw miles loved it what what in where I
don't know I was left okay drop it
Darren Darren pick me up took me back to
his house outside of Darren's house it
was a single brick wide brick wall
imagine terraced streets that you see
typical turn side flats and Newcastle
sat down on the wall and the wall was
ready to go crumbly concrete between a
lot cracked through the wall so an
entire small wall of bricks 50 bricks
went over look like a car attraction to
this person but Darren lived in the maze
and that's upstairs so I had broken his
next-door neighbor's wall went upstairs
in the dirt so Darren I'd lost my keys
that was it had lost my key so I can get
to my house Darla take me back to his I
went up the stairs tried to go to the
bathroom was aiming for the toilet with
wing into the toilet lost my balance
fell sideways into the bath and then
pissed all over myself while I was in
the bath cracked the bottom of the bath
as well so split his bath in half and
then pissed onto myself and through the
cracked bath into the floorboards
underneath
woke up in the morning and realized that
I had to get a bus to Perth in Scotland
to go and collect this new car which was
my 23rd birthday present to myself spent
the entire day limping around because I
was now sober with a stonking hangover
and had to get what was it cup it was a
red Olmec gun our 26r everyone black
like I remember
yeah it was nice and fast and lovely but
this story to go and get it like I
picked it up at 10:00 p.m. at night and
then drove back so woke up with a
hangover Darren's house couldn't get
into my house none of my flatmates are
there piss all over me his girlfriend
now wife was very angry with me
broken bath broken bath I had injured my
knee to spend my entire day on busses up
to Perth finally got there about 8:00
p.m. at night had to hand over all of
this money to this guy drove the car
back in 5th gear didn't realise had six
keys so drove it back in five in 5th all
the way home and then remember looking
at my watch as I got in and I thought
it's five minutes past midnight that's
my birthday gun [ __ ]
I am [ __ ] right let's gone can we learn
about when you joined a cult please yeah
so we have been begging him to tell us I
think or Lisa should do too for our ones
fine
two to one worked right so I'll do both
of your requests Carlton a big pivot
toilet so we I think all of these
stories start from ok position of like
being experimental and not having such
FOMO of like but what if there is
something to it what if what if I do
spend three weeks in the pool yeah
underwater two hours a day and actually
it is slightly beneficial so the cult
was something that was recommended to me
I thought I'm gonna join it I probably
shouldn't say the name of it because can
you give it an alternative name yeah
Grubb leave up so cool
the I joined the grumpy book cult and it
basically involves going to barrack and
stuffing standing in a dark room with
some old men just from our clarity when
did this happen
this was
yeah so sorry summer 2017 doesn't ever
find out well cuz it would at the time
it was just another experimental is like
a like there's a plane I'm gonna test
the claim gonna join it okay I was like
I and I don't join like a Louis Theroux
skeptic I fully am i right I'm fully on
board with this potentially working we
want you're innocent until proven guilty
so did we decide une one I'm gonna go
join the cult or were you like I'm off
to join the cult no I came back told my
flatmate everything as are and American
trying to codes are cool me David is
most unfazed so went to barracks stood
in a room with old man some adult men
they say begin the old man start
speaking in tongues and so running
around moving and what they were just
normal clothes wears like old men
clothes like cords and Jack don't show
you is checkered shirt official a PFC
shoes off when you go in the room no
shoes and I'm I'm standing there and
everyone's like supposedly being what
looks like being possessed by something
I'm thinking why isn't this working
I want the the fun the tangs the tongues
and stuff so there's like okay yeah
eventually and it went on for half an
hour and then we'll do this I'm standing
it's on accounting lie on the floor did
anyone run over you know so that was a
suspicious thing because they're running
around the room and supposedly totally
out of control out of the bodies but
they're this under coordinated enough to
not stand on you so the spirits that
possessed them were at least polite we
were polite enough yeah and then I went
every Saturday morning at 8 a.m. to a
community center to do this just me and
one other guy who was the representative
for the Northeast and he was very
patient with me like he was like it's
not working for me like don't worry to
persevere so I did every Saturday
morning for 10 weeks this is a podcast
eventually I was like look I really want
to give this not a shot because there's
no point just saying ah
try that it didn't work but I want I
want the Pugh one and then I want the
nocturnal emission okay that's not as
much favorite customer in the VA
hospital I have you heard the story
about flying the Isle of Man all the
guns of the German lady yeah okay right
so just before you move on what was what
was supposed to happen with the Colt
what's supposed to also do like I don't
know whether it's maybe suggestibility
so like they because they were really
into it like it speaking I don't think
that you're particularly suggested lord
it's a shame good I want it to be that's
the annoying thing but they go you don't
want to be suggested with us they know
it won't actually we don't go and think
our comment get possessed like what do
they trying to do but they I'm gonna
call it possessed but they like yeah so
the spirit moves through them or
something like that but I did feel I
felt like the steady one which is which
is incredibly bizarre but you felt like
the silly one lying on the floor look I
love the commitment 10 weeks to barrack
community center yeah the local one was
just all rights remember when I came
around to your house and we had a huge
bowl of spinach in front of you and you
were eating raw spinach from the bowl
and I said why are you eating that
massive bowl of spinach and you said I'm
not sure I'd read something at some
point that said eating a bowl of spinach
was good for me but I can't remember
what it was and I can't remember the
effect it's supposed to elicit when you
like you find yourself in a situation
you know Arman passed me a scuppered
take the chicken out
passed me did myself a favor but didn't
explain why so Paul I have a calendar
invite saying eat 200 grams of spinach
like I have read this and it is and I'm
very fine it is okay like I trust past
me more than anyone why is so much is
that you just go okay time to do that
then when you used to do it over so what
was the other big poop in the toilet
story we were talking on the previous
podcast last week or some week some week
Time Warp week about do not live with
seven people lived in a flat with seven
people
someone did a big big poo in the toilet
and it blocked it got halfway caught up
the u-bend
wouldn't move at all and then it's a
case of just continue to on top of it so
i boiled the kettle on the people were
all my flatmate who is one of the
smartest people I've ever met but has a
very odd way of things David well yeah
not really in a I don't have to describe
it because if I try it's gonna sound
like he has Asperger's it's not in that
same vein but anyway he walked to the
nearest field which is a mile
way to get a stick and walked back
dislodge the poo at the stake and then
didn't know what to do with the poopy
stick so he took it back to the field
[Music]
four miles away just and I took the mick
out of him so I was like why did he have
to go like I understand getting the
stick from the field line and just about
but you didn't need to go and put it
back in the same field like it no one's
gonna miss it as part of that for me I
don't know why it feels like it's key is
complete it's black in the field for
circle yeah yeah with poop but with poop
but the period of matter in the field of
surgeries let me put in the field anyway
what if someone else got to do the same
thing with that same stick take the end
well Taron you face that risk to begin
with he was okay with that right that's
true yeah what if he already did oh
that's the poo stick yeah this thing so
I cast I think with re no I think you
should can we do I've got another
cracking one don't do it I don't know if
you know I want I want I want novelty
come on
okay Johnny and I were at a competition
in Leeds and we were we so to start with
actually that this is this is your life
fail um so Johnny's Johnny just bought
an Apple watch I turned up in his heart
at his parents house at 7:00 a.m. saying
hi
is Johnny ready to go his mum's like I
don't know I've not seen him yet and
then I just hear like [ __ ] Johnny comes
running downstairs looking really groggy
and red I just like Oh what time is it
oh no I set my alarm but it didn't go
off I was like what do you mean it was
like well what happened is my Apple
watch at 4 a.m.
started buzzing and making noise going
oh you've been sat down to long time to
start them you've been sedentary for too
long so so I got a runner on the rim he
tried to like get ready and then Becca
was was like what are you doing
and I was like the new turned you turned
the alarm off went back to sleep step
because then you're so pissed off at
your Apple watch you're like
more arrests yeah so you went to the
meet one so we ended up going to the
meet a bit late we made the way in and
so on the realization of what happened
on so long day lots of caffeine like and
if you heard our opinions on caffeine
I'm a very low caffeine to person so
taking pill form caffeine is a kind of
rocket fuel driving back 7 or 8 p.m.
final stretch I'm like an hour away from
home and this on the motorway and this
woman jumps off different or not them in
front of me in bits like in tears so I
just put the brakes on roll down the
window like are you alright yeah get in
so this is where you get followed isn't
it
this y'all might even see this one I saw
this one so I've let this woman is the
car she's in she's absolutely distraught
I'm I'm already not kid and I'm thinking
like is this a safe situation is it one
of these scams I thought when I stopped
the car is that one of those things
where I like they distract you them two
guys come into the car and Jackie car
and bu er so anyway had her in the car
she's telling me a story that doesn't
quite match up about has been kicking
her out of the car and she wants me to
take her to the next town alone I'm like
okay fine like I'm in this situation now
as we are driving there there's two
women walking along a pavement she rolls
down the window and shots yeah get in to
those two and I'm like whoa I agreed to
pick you up I didn't agree to pick up
all your may so I don't know who these
people and then she's just like doesn't
respond very normally to that we carry
on she's like I live in that residence
so I start going towards it car comes up
behind me like old Vauxhall Corsa
flashing the lights beeping the horn
four guys in it proper Raji's like the
like the bird and the deer Dora trucks
eat a lot flashing the lights beeping me
so I just pull over and let them go
because they're right right my back
they then pull round and stop in front
of me
so I pull off again and then they they
pull off once again right behind the
back pull around once again stop in
front of me in the road so I can't get
out I can't I can't go around them all
the four doors open the four guys get
out start walking towards the car so I'm
like was this so I pull off again they
get back in the car and drive and drive
after me at this point I'm like right
and she's just unperturbed by the whole
thing if your heart rate must have been
I yeah I think there was a lot of like
decision trees going on later sir and
then she was are left here back here
right here Aniston to like more and more
of it like dead end he bit and the guys
are following me eventually they just
peel off and I'm like okay she then
takes me to what she says it's her house
she'd been talking about me husband I've
got a killer I'm actually gonna kill him
I'm gonna take your knife and I'm like
listen please like for my sake maybe got
accessory accessory to murder and also
like I said listen right go in your
house go straight to bed
do not pass go do not speak to your
husband just have a sleep you'd be ok no
more deal with it in the morning
don't while your emotions are high just
and she's like oh really pulled me into
the house I'm gonna kill her like listen
I took one thing the trooper so I kind
of give me some money on that no just
don't was gonna kill you muster all I'm
asking of you she wants me to pull into
her house and I'm thinking if I pull in
with this guy who sounds like an
absolute nutter and she and he's like
who's this young man let's go enjoy
sorry yeah I was like I'm gonna get axed
like I'm just missed being killed by for
Linda by for chest so I was like look
okay we can see you ask there is 20
meters away just just go
off you pop and then what happened and
then I got out and it was fun she got on
it was all fine amazing Johnny and then
he told me about it and I advised him
not to be done and he liked all my
images when I was I had too much to
drink
oh I can think of it's the time when I
about a house-party toilet and now his
party his B is being used just one B
upon naturally you just won't be upon
desperate for the desperate the toilet
go upstairs they'd found out someone's
getting a [ __ ] in the toilet was
extremely annoying balance well kids
because of what happened next
what's this walked outside what around
the side of the house started pissing
literally pissed into the wind and the
pitch went although you mean so soaked
but what was so strange about the
experience I really clearly remember
this was styling pissing piss all over
my t-shirt and then just thought well
it's done now so I should continue
pissing it's gone and it went like
litter in my face and then I went back
in again and everyone's like why so wet
and I just maintained the line of it's
raining outside that reminds me of the
Peep Show
when what mark is in the stationery
cupboard and Dobby starts grinding on
him this is does she mean to do this
oh god oh I've come in my pants that's
actually hot and then he walked
something's going grey trousers and he's
got a small little wet patch on his
trousers yeah then graduate yeah I got
you you pissed yourself
like yes yeah so I literally piss into
the wind and then passed all over myself
literally and that the following day is
our worst hangover I've ever had really
it's red wine yeah two bottles of red
wine Wow and then beer my worst ever
having a bro thing cuz
take me out that was borrow me it's
incredible when did you tell us that
story on the Technion podcast which may
have may or may not have already existed
if it's not coming a hugger of a story
though it's an absolute belter very
evening I think of anything to mention
so there's a couple I've mentioned
before so you made your mom cry with
notice talk if I don't but that's the
story
let's do Ben let's do what happened with
her nan yeah that's who
so okay I can i can actually country to
this on so we I went to go and see
Johnny capiz first-ever powerlifting
meet in Ashington so wasn't first-ever
this was like a year ago my you're the
first time that I've ever seen you
competed on lifting me Asian and Asian
and for people who've never been to
powerlifting meets before it's just like
a testosterone filled room of chalk and
metal and people shouting and talk about
and old men little in a nightie room of
the community center yeah it's it's in
and that's what that's what strangest
about it the fact that you've got this
hyper aggressive super strong kind of
culture and then it's just being
deposited into a school the first
welfare Center a school sports hall and
they've had to move the a-frame from
from primary school to one side so that
they can get the warden what's most
mental about that as you walk down the
corridor to the warm-up room and there's
like children's sort of paints all over
the walls I get into the gym and there's
like three or four world champions trade
in that gym and always have trained in
that gym and it's just the most out of
place thing is the whole thing is just a
bit uneasy there everything about the
room like everyone has the same postural
deficits like they're all they're all
lordotic like busting now it quads
everywhere as my aide sort of piercings
yeah
so yeah anything else Chris I was there
and then there was my mom yes
because that here so anyway we're
watching watching Johnny short to
getting shorter well watching Johnny get
rid of your left and in powerlifting
there is something called nose talk
which is a specific kind of smelling
salt so ammonia I think we should give
some give some background on this as
well the smelling salts are one thing
and paramedics give to drug people right
it is but like smelling salts are some
nose talk what a you're good with these
analogies it's like a bullet to a
nuclear warhead yeah it's like it's it's
so concentrated because it's just like a
block over the pure stuff no it's
actually ammonia it isn't bit ammonia
and if you if you open it in a room of
this size within a few seconds everyone
ah like it's it's so strong and what's
the reason for it so they they use it to
wake people up but they also use it to
test if someone is malingering and
claiming that through some you know
through something of lawsuits that
they've lost their sense of smell mmm
people will probably notice that no
store or not or like ammonia not the
brand of nose talked under that nose and
say can you smell this and the people
who are lying will be like no I can't
smell it but actually it's not processed
as a scent as a smell it's processed as
pain okay as it strips you sinuses so
it's and they you guys sniff it before
you lift to counties also I don't like I
like I have you ever used it before
lifting no one time and it was a bad
idea terrible well people you get really
amped up before lifting it is completely
and utterly unnecessary it's a technical
sport but the strongest people in the
world Karma's a Hindu cow like they just
walk on lift the weight then walk off
again unless you're Stephen manual but
there are people stronger than him who
register so like it just shows it's not
required like it fair enough if you
wanna make a fuss but everyone's got the
different you know nice easily of course
do so yeah and um Ben who was one of
Johnny's fans was um was sat in the
crowd and we were saying well lucky she
did everyone should have smell of this
and I got pushed quite hard towards
smell
and I stood my ground because I knew
that it would be a bad idea for me
roaming that Johnny hasn't actually so
because you've been exposed to too many
people in clubs oh no you're gay hang on
I've seen that being a before and Ben
got bullied into doing it remembering
that Johnny hasn't actually lifted yet
and Ben's gone all the way to Ashington
to be able to watch him lift someone the
use of opens this non-stop and bet I
thought that was just gonna give it like
it which is more than enough
like that's what people do before they
lift is they go it's but even then they
go well it's a couple of feet below that
notes right it's not like it's not like
smelling we know one of those all of us
oil sticks are actually attached to your
nose and that's how Ben went for it so
Ben went for a two nostril offensive
about half an inch of both the opening
to it
big breath instantly site yelping in
pain is I started streaming Ben looks a
little bit soft like at the best of
times and then looked like said from Ice
Age in a really sad scene like when he
lost his chestnut and then was in so
much pain I had to go to the toilets to
try and wash his eyes so that his eyes
would stop streaming that didn't work
missed Johnny's first lift because the
nodes talk and just ruined the rest of
his date he went home early yeah I
remember seeing him five hours later and
he was still red eyes we went for a meal
later on Johnny turned up from zoologist
Penrith Ben he's an intensive care you
were like half where the door you're
like seriously but the best thing about
that is asked Ben left he just I so I
didn't see this happen but he just
turned to my moment back and just went
thank you thank you so much and no one
knew what he was thanking them for and
he doesn't know what he was thanking me
for it's just this is instinctive yes
you are a gent like you could have taken
that so much worse I know that's very
per right
Yussef what we go okay so this is one I
think Johnny said you haven't heard this
year I've just finished an obstetrics
and gynecology rotation so pregnant
vaginas and I went into I was it was
5:30 I was with it I was in a clinic and
I was like right can I can I go now yeah
if you found it useful I was like yeah
it's been it's been good like I forgot
to do an examination or one of the
patients better oh I wouldn't know I
would arrange for you to doing something
else okay I'm cool I'm cool
she's caught cause up the next boys like
I have a student here's what he was
doing examination on that it's 5:30
likely and Jews oh no no no don't worry
don't worry and so send me off to
another ward someone else met me and was
like ah you need to get because you have
to get things signed off as part of you
see observed examinations of certain
things and it was examining a pregnant
woman and so I turned up and I'm like hi
yeah I've been sent over like do you
have any pregnant women that I can look
at look at and examine and to feel the
bump and stuff not just like feels like
yeah she was like yeah want to do a baby
show she was like yeah okay this one
here went into an isolation room and
this doctor came in was like hi there
Victoria how are you doing yeah you've
had a lot of syphilis haven't you yeah
yeah anyway we've got this students just
wants to run to perform an examination
for his for his workbook and that's like
some watching my heart isn't okay and
then just revealed the belly and make it
from the waist down and the up part of
it is you have to like when you're
measuring the baby you have to get right
into sort of the top of the vagina
runway if you don't wear gloves for this
one and then like afterwards finished
the exam washed my hands vigorously left
the room just like that one and then how
to chart in the stock drop it I was like
so you said you have a lot of syphilis
she was I'm sorry what so you certainly
came in you are high you've had a lot of
syphilis she was like our sickness
anything like because for someone to be
described as having a lot of sick that's
like I can't believe that they the you
thought like yeah I'm just going in no
gloves what a syphilis here I was that
I've committed now like and and putting
on gloves for something like that is a
bit insulting
so but in anyway next next to Mary I'll
I'll jump in I've got a quickly okay so
as it often happens with nightclubs if I
stood in the door of a of a venue a lot
of time bouncers on the door will
confiscate drugs from people who've been
going into clubs so I went to Thailand a
couple of years ago and I'd be working
on the night a few weeks before that and
got herself out to Thailand had flown by
Dubai
well it's Thailand and had been fighting
and training in and white I count which
men had been living in shorts for most
of the time and on the Saturday all of
the fibers go out and they have a meal
night meal side put my pair of jeans on
and a shirt a nut got out gone to for
this meal and then gone to a bar
afterwards got in the bar and I put my
money so I didn't have a wallet on me so
I'm not going between all of my pockets
put my hand into the little pocket that
goes in the top of you jeans and pulled
out a full Graham bag of miscellaneous
drugs which one of the door staff had
given me miscellaneous well just hit
undiagnosed Ryan unknown white powder
I'm so glad that you've said the story I
was worried that you wouldn't say it's
one of my favorites so I've had this I'm
supposed to have put it in the safe but
I'm running around outside of a
nightclub and I've forgotten remembering
that I've flown through Dubai where its
life in prison for having drugs on you
and then arrived in Thailand where the
penalty can be death they still have the
death penalty for Class A drugs over
there and at which point I would like
has a near mental breakdown and then I
actually ended up throwing it in a river
it's realizing the enormity of what
it's the 8 it's such an odd sensation
that something terrible has happened
whilst nothing at all happening there
was exactly well as how I felt with the
police cars and the approval and stuff
if you like or something
something Awful's occurred but actually
at the same time nothing it's awful
nothing awful is good I'm gonna do
another one actually while I'm on this
topic so I said this story to you today
this is quite an interesting insight
into how much we value were the people's
opinions of ourselves so I was in Bali
last year I just need to stop going away
in the stomach is just mad [ __ ]
happening I was in Bali last year I was
driving a 50 pence per day Balinese
moped and I truck pulled out on me while
I was driving on Balinese Road I had a
hell of I was wearing tiny swim shorts
in the best slammer brakes on the back
wheel started to skid out so release the
brakes bike straightened up but then I
was about 5 yards away from the truck so
I could have either pulled the brakes a
game and risked skidding or allowed
myself to hit this truck I was like
right lesser of two evils pull the brake
to go and see what happens sure enough
bike went out from underneath me me and
my tiny swim shorts was like along the
ground all on one side so it was elbow
shoulder knee outside of front of shin
and then all of the top of my foot so
all of the skin was just removed I think
you guys you guys knew enough to it yeah
pretty gruesome like very very painful
injuries afterwards but at the time I
didn't feel any the prevailing sensation
the prevailing emotion I had was
embarrassment so ahead of fear of
physical injury pain disfigurement
self-preservation any of those things is
that I lost you
the prevailing feeling was I have like a
[ __ ] but I had a couple of guys that I
was a writer that you like I'm the white
guy on the moped a little bit well the
others a stereotype of like
[ __ ] tourists yeah and then a couple
of the guys I was riding with came back
and they came over they're like [ __ ]
hell mate you alright I was like yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'll be okay
like I've removed most of the skin from
one side of from my arm and leg from one
side of my body and the entire top of my
foot has gone and I'm there saying yay
and I'm fine like let's just crack on no
I know we need to go a pharmacy that's
all right okay let's go a pharmacy that
sure enough as the adrenaline begins to
wear off a little bit and the pain
starts to kick in and this is probably
the most in terms of total amount of
pain like area under the pain curve for
the next four weeks are the most painful
thing I've ever had to deal with but as
it happened the first 10 to 15 seconds
afterwards all I really felt was
embarrassment can you also just describe
the alcohol swabs ah yeah so and this is
how did I miss this as a life phone
honestly it's wood for the trees again
isn't it like yeah so I was on my way to
a beach club and I was with two guys one
of whom is an Aussie so his and Bothan
worked offshore so they were like fully
medically trained pulled in to a
pharmacy picked up some alcohol wipes
and some dressing some tea tree oil and
some other stuff that would cleanse it
and some iodine and they were like well
we might as well my halfway to this
Beach Club and we need to get you
cleaned up so you might as well come
with us we'll do that have a couple of
beers and we'll turn around Remmy like
disappoint all of the skin from the
front of my shoulder like my hand to his
shoulder all of my elbow and halfway
down my forearm the outside of my knee
took a lot of the impact and then a
lighter grazing but still all the front
of my shin on the outside and then
literally the top of my foot he's gone
so we pull into this really nice beach
club and the guys who are doing like the
the valet service outside just looking
us up and down and they're on the left
hand side of me which is this side that
has got and then just look at me as I go
past it's bright red like blood red
anyway my man you okay I'm like yeah no
no don't worry about it don't worry
get into the Beach Club go into the
bathroom and it's a really nice posh
beach club where they've got miniature
hand towels it's just as well because I
needed to use those to pick bits of
Balinese Road out of my flesh so is that
right before we sell out the tightest
road isn't it yeah well it was course
like gravel and big chunks in the road
so it was like hitting a cheese grate
like it hang concrete cheese grater
firms anyway starting to wash my wounds
with this water and it's I can feel like
the severity what was worse was the
severity of my injuries got worse that
went down so shoulder was worse than
elbow was worse than me was worse than
foot and the foot was really bad so I've
got this drinking water I kind of
swashing it on and I can feel that like
stinging sensation like very very
strongly it's just exposed flesh
basically and a little droplet of water
just went down and hit the top of my
foot so I was doing that and it just set
it on fire
I couldn't believe how painful it was
and I was like [ __ ] sake so I'm like
kind of shaking a little bit but also
oddly out of my body at the same time I
think probably a dunk of adrenaline on
the back end and a few other bits so
I've got these tackles and I'm like
picking bits of gravel out of the side
of my leg and like trying to dab certain
digital trying to dab different bits of
my body down just so I can get used to
the pressure being on it I'm not right
okay no worries anyway go back in and
sit down with the boys and I look how
are you feeling that's like yeah like
you know I've got got a bit water on it
and know that look that we need to do we
need to get the wounds clean do we need
to get dressed I need to do all the rest
of it right okay well like let me have a
beer love a beer we'll crack on so have
a beer is that right sweet should we get
side as I kept cool no worries so he
gets a alcohol swab a little square
alcohol swab that you'd usually use
before you get like a hypodermic
that goes in and I remember he just the
weight you can imagine the weight earth
I probably weighs like two grandmas or
three grams and he just like brushed the
top of my shoulder with it so didn't
actually apply any pressure just allowed
the weight of the thing to drape itself
across my shoulder and I thought that I
understood what the maximum volume was
that my nerves were able to communicate
to my brain and this just smashed
through it and turned it up to like 11
or 12 and I could hear the pain like it
was like the tinnitus sound and my
shoulders went to him like I was hearing
something loud and he just brushed it
across the top and I was like a holy
[ __ ] that that is beyond anything I've
ever ever felt but then after about five
seconds five to ten seconds the nerves
just completely shut off so you can
imagine the draped it across and that
happened for the first time unbelievable
pain but once all of the nerves have
fried themselves he can that actually
apply as much pressure as he wants and
it doesn't feel like anything anymore
she's really interesting phenomena I
don't really understand why or how that
works well there was there's a Malcolm
Gladwell one the other one there's two
authors I got mixed up anyway one of
them was on a burns unit for a while
obviously got full body burns and he
said the nurses out of compassion would
try to when they had to replace people's
dressings once a day they would undo the
bandages slowly then and the patient
started to develop a real anxiety when
it came to the bandages being done and
it turned out that actually he suggested
after experiencing both himself fast and
slow he was like actually fast as much
better yeah over because slow is just
this ongoing he was like this month
hasn't experienced regardless yeah so he
suggested like that's just switched to
squash and it did and so so
so yeah done that one then did elbow as
well dressed it put this lovely dressing
up for the iodine arm it should have
hurt but again the nerves are just
transmitting nothing and I'm like
sweating it hot really mom I'm sweating
unbelievable about pain and then look
voice I can eat another couple of beers
so I'm like having have maybe two or
three more beers remembering that I need
to drive the bike back about this is at
the time I was like like just to get
through this I need to get through this
forget about driving back anyways I look
mate like we need to crack on I need to
do this because he was worried about me
being exposed to the air just like
particles in the air and stuff like that
I don't rely on truths and that
especially in burliest but this yeah but
we right next to the beach and etc etc
so anyway just my me and that's like
that's another nother level of pain
remembering I already thought it just
got turned up to 11 and that was another
level of pain and I remember watching
the guy who sat cross from us as he
helplessly saw one of his friends
inflict pain on another one of his
friends and the guy that was doing it to
me was going I'm sorry I'm sorry
and I was like hey it's fine go I know
what I'm so sorry I'm just really sorry
I'm so sorry I was like maybe it's okay
like you doing what you need to do is
that right okay and then it was gonna
get to my foot and my foot was just a
complete the whole top of it had gone
and I was like right [ __ ] out another
couple of beers so I'm like heavily be a
deep now but alright and anyway I
remember that right just go for it so he
puts this thing across the top of my
foot and then I just read Born to Run
and it's a book about African tribes
long distance running and stuff like
that
and in that they talk about when they're
suffering with pain when they're running
about rather than hiding from the pain
they go into it and they open the pain
up they go to the exact sort of the
epicenter exactly where it comes from
and they deconstruct it and think about
what it actually means and then it
dissipates
and I was that right well you know I've
never got a better pair time to try and
try this experiment than now so he did
it and sure enough and pain was
unbelievable had nothing I've ever ever
felt before but very very quickly it
stopped being pain like I wasn't I
wasn't
I didn't attach myself to the pain or
associate anything with the pain
remembering that this was something that
was good for me as well and after maybe
one second of kind of establishing
myself with what the feeling was going
to be that's like laughing so this is
and still I can still say it's the most
painful experience but it wasn't
traumatic when it happened and it was
just really really interesting that that
had occurred and he'd done this across
the top of my foot and then sure enough
I knew that in five to ten seconds it
was all going to be over and I was going
to be fine and it would be strapped up
and my wound would be clear cleaner and
etc etc but yeah that was that was
really really interesting like that
sensation of the pain and being able to
go down and think it's just as well I
feel very thankful I've done even a
modicum of mindfulness practice over the
last of the 18 months before that also
I'm quite consistently and I've done a
lot while I was out there so without
that I think I'd have touched myself to
the pain an awful lot more and about a
narrative around me then you're a few
beers deep and you've gotta get a bike
back I had to drive / me nah that was
fine like I had no one thing that would
have been residual would have been
travel anxiety yeah but um that was that
was precession that those pretty much
all got by the beers and then got my can
I had to cut my trip back from Bali
short so I've been planning this trip to
Bali for a year was supposed to go for a
month fell off a bike after a week and
came back home after a fortnight
lifehack failed that is a fail fail and
a half have we got a short one to the
year so there's a few mini ones to him
any one did we do this the data charge
on the novel plate no sir
on the way to Thailand I fell asleep and
I was naughty you know they're like
Mitch make sure you turn your phone on
airplane mode I was like that so [ __ ]
you mother
so so I just I fell asleep and we were
still over the UK 35 minutes into the
flight and I woke up for a moment
checked my phone so they'll have a text
message hi welcome to aeromobil you are
now using our services connected with
your third phone you are being charged 7
pounds per megabyte for data and million
pounds for minutes and messages Oh God
so I checked my daily data usage on the
settings and it said 526 megabytes I was
like oh right ok hello quickly like
immediately airplane mode calculator x 7
pounds last 3700 pounds like I'm gonna
have to sell the car sell my kidney like
this and I'll suck they're just mincing
for the next 24 hours
Zuzu's 22-hour flight and obviously like
and you're just trapped unable to turn
it off you've got no network access no
network access knowing that I've just
got this massive impending bill that's
way beyond what I can afford somewhere
just like so hot for falling asleep
there wasn't even using it I understand
like but it's so it's like you you just
they've just come into you into your
pocket and they've just gone so it's
just a beautiful freshening the
background yeah and what was because you
didn't actually end up believing in so
it ended up like luckily in Dubai
Airport like 12 hours later managed to
get access to Wi-Fi sent a message to
Vodafone customer service and all this
stuff from like I'm gonna get absolutely
ruined here eventually a few days later
by the time the bill did refresh it only
charged 36 pounds and by wish but I was
so relieved that did you can test that
yeah
oh good also like on principle that what
they've done is they like when your
phone isn't even in use you're literally
asleep they just come in and reach and I
suppose the their room the reaction to
that as well you're upsetting your phone
and oh but that's true so but then say I
agree well there will be massive
financial consequences this is this a
potential flight risk my thinking is
that like if if modern planes can't
handle a bit of EMF from someone's phone
and and like the level of security that
they enforce that is like reminding
people in one language from
multinational flights to turn phone off
that's what I think I've upped about the
liquids thing like I you know 9/11 was
terrible me don't it happen again but
I've accidentally flown with 125
milliliters of toothpaste in my hand
luggage you know one stopped me
yeah like well it's just a it's just an
absolute plot unless someone would like
to tell us in the comments below why
they do that well there's a YouTube
video where this guy makes a shotgun
from things that he's bought in the
airport have you seen that no condom
battery pack of deodorant bunch of
change and a hair dryer and so he takes
the heating unit from the hair dryer
touches it to a toilet tube puts the
coins in like a
pack at the end of it wraps a condom
filled with the battery inside the head
the hair dryer heating unit and the
count of deodorant behind as the as the
explosive thing and basically it just it
melts through him and it fires the coins
and this is what Amy's like I bought all
the stuff for twelve dollars in and does
your show like the destruction yeah it's
a very dirty gun like it it's very
unpredictable but the fact is like you
can do some pretty serious damage also I
kept a diary from everyday I wrote a
daily account of what happened it was it
wasn't so much like an outpouring of
emotion diary it was just like this
happened on this day like a journal for
ten years
was it ten years yeah and nothing from
like eight years from like the age of
yeah the age of eleven to the age of 19
and then one day I was just adding to it
and it was Microsoft Word document
which is why Microsoft Word can go in
like just and the file corrupted no oh
well that's it ten years of my life my
diary just stops then and like well I'm
not gonna continue from now so no more
diarrhea do you ever think that the
things that have happened to you are
exceptional
a lot of it self-inflicted like I
shouldn't have been a Microsoft Word
document that was the universe saying
uses me it's a drop in the ocean
compared to driving tabarak to Jordan
Cole though isn't it really well so
forcing yourself to be submerged under
water in the cotton corner of Jasmine
pool for two hours every day also the
the sense of like Oh God when you found
the pack of drugs yeah a similar thing I
had my laptop in the back of the car I
went and went for a meal when I came
back I realized that I'd left both
backdoors
what like white aeroplane wide open with
a laptop in the back
Oh Joe you I mean he left you I left
your keys on the passenger seat if you
just sort of locked car in the
supermarket today yeah it's quite a
rough car apart like so I would actually
think about this I was walking towards
the car and they were like there was a
kiln clear smell of weed coming from one
parked car
two guys just kind of loitering around
and you just think like dodgy here so
but then thought process was so when I
work in a coffee shop I take my laptop
with me in the toilet I can't decide
whether or not that's a weird thing to
do but it's this thought I think that
other people might look at you and they
think what a weirdo but like I have the
last laugh I'm not trust the public too
different to defend your property but
absolutely not it's what been mugged in
broad broad daylight on a bigger punch
bowl that's on a busy street than Pushpa
Narsee
Oh
everything that's happened to me in
anything criminal has happened to me has
been in broad really daylight and no one
helps something like you're absolutely
right you know what fire fire percentage
of people have that desire to say except
I think I think that I have because I'm
naturally I think I'm naturally quite a
nice person I'm a you know a fair person
who wouldn't want this steal someone's
[ __ ] laptop that they left out hmm
I give an unjú level of leeway and hope
to other members of the general thinking
though yeah
but it only takes one time your car to
be stolen or my business partner days
got his car stolen I think I've told you
this story so they the robbers go into
his house these brand new q7 60 70 grand
q7 outside going to his house and his
bedroom is on the first floor so got his
stead came in with bedroom he's in the
bedroom he's in a bedroom asleep
he wears earplugs and allow my success
sleepin took the keys from next to his
head really on his bedside the flagrant
isn't it just took the keys and then
instead of going back down thinking done
that mmm when open another flight of
stairs into his brother's room and took
the laptop I just sold his brother
unbelievable from his brother was asleep
as well just the same thing obviously
they don't know I mask they don't know
earplugs
mm-hm took that came back down bundled
his brother's laptop into either the
brother's car drove away never got it
back that's crazy
David Cameron had his bike stolen
outside of Tesco in London because he he
locked it on one of those Bhalla that's
that high slider does it yeah and then
he was being interviewed up as I had
just done I was only in there five
minutes
like David welcome the real world yeah
like okay I appreciate you like taking
your bike out onto the street as a PR
event but like but it's the things that
look like Prabhu the last David here's
something became like [ __ ] you it's like
I can't I have no idea of what
proportion of people because so that
makes me in the same coffee shop the
other day was a guy on his laptop
he was just regularly getting up and
going outside for a cigarette
hmm which is a bit weird in itself
because you don't you go outside from he
cigarette but he was just leaving his
laptop that is their only one entrance
and exit there is but like what's he
going to do
he was like an Oh a quite an old guy
like is he gonna have an easier to
confront the person because there's
gonna be that moment where someone
walked out with his laptop he's gonna go
you stop my laptop and then he's gonna
come in and look realize his laptops not
there and it's too much that's mighty
minutes but smash him in the face of the
e-cigarette pour in the eye I told you
about the man that came to the door yeah
that's a very vague
sorry boom well I was this the person
who you resuscitated wearing a skirt oh
okay so that's another one as well but
so I I was in the flat something knock
at the door this guy like in a shirt and
trousers and his hair kind of slicked
back look a bit slimy was like hi there
um I'm just if the shoes sorry I do know
this yeah it's like it's salmon and I
like some then the rest of the fast huh
come here I'm peering out at this guy
and it's like oh you're right mate and
he walks into the other room like how do
you know somehow I don't I'm just here
for his shoes like well it's the same
guy he wouldn't the feel for the stick
no there's someone differently different
um and so this guy was like like look
can you tell it seems like if you must
know I've got a foot fetish and I'd
appreciate if you wouldn't judge me but
I I've just come for some shoes it
sounds like bras shoes right alright man
enjoy see you later like totally fine
about it like what's going on in some of
the are you followed me the other day
and it was like yeah
I really ruin shoes and I really like
the shoes can I can I have them and I
was like yeah sure me but I haven't I
need to get any pair on Friday so it
just come back then I never appear and
so the guy as instructed came out came
back is a schooi bazaar can we finish
showing you resuscitating sonnet yeah
sure
we were like summer you're not um are
you okay with what that man's gonna be
doing with your shoes and he was like
yeah finally over what's the what's the
thought experiment that you do about
someone taking sexual pleasure from
giving you a massage
oh yeah so this is the so there's a book
called the ethics of touch and I was
recommended to anyone who is a clinician
or suppose that involves touching
someone fits it yeah this thing's like
if somebody was massaging you and they
were getting so much a lot of enjoyment
from it themselves is that but that
doesn't change your experience of the
massage but is it something that you are
uncomfortable with assuming let's say
you're a straight man it's another man
and the man is getting enjoyment from it
mmm-hmm is he getting or awardable or
visual no no he's who's giving no
signals that does matter anyway so for
you you your utilitarian doesn't seem as
long as he is so when you I think you
asked me this question recently and in
my head I'm like I imagine that I can
tell ya in our case I know that's wrong
okay yeah I see so until it impinges on
your experience you don't mind well yeah
well because how many like we may have
all all the massages you've had may have
been with someone absolutely loving
every second but you don't know you know
worse off hmm
what about if you knew in retrospect
what about if someone told you after the
event I said I think I could suspend the
thoughts as long as you know I thought
however why mindfulness gap yeah
meditation and why is that different to
date rape because date rape is a is a
horrific thing and most people would
agree that it would be that's very much
a violation but because you are I'm
still allowing permission for the
massage to happen you're not allowing
permission for
take sexual pleasure from it though it
rights granted you know why it's a it's
a completely different picking up but
this hasn't been so date rape there's no
permission at all the whole thing's been
stolen okay yeah true so what about what
about someone peep holing you going to
the bathroom through a people and you
not knowing about it fine what's the
problem with that H let's explain in the
simplest way possible while to problem
it is an ethical problem isn't it for
him because you didn't consent to it but
with the Mossad you like but you didn't
consent to the thing which is the crux
of what would discuss it so in the
muscle of case like whether the like we
you wouldn't necessarily want the
therapist to be having a bad time as
much as you wouldn't want them to be
having good time you would want it to
hurt them to get it to be hating it so
actually it's irrelevant to you and if
anything you'd want them to be having at
least a nice time but yet but then you
can overshoot I think there's every
Jannetty that that they really enjoy
doing it you have to assume that that
irrational person that they they do what
they can you say or are you saying that
we're hoping with you is a pleasurable
experience I'm saying that they've taken
they've gone down consciously trained
and pursuing a career path that's solely
involved huh well so you're saying it
doesn't matter whether the enjoyment is
like really enjoying the money I get for
this
or oh I'm really enjoying this whereas
Chris you are less comfortable with them
enjoying the activist so you're okay
with them enjoying the the compensation
for the afternoon I think it's just very
interesting I think it's just an
interesting thought experiment you think
that massively I think that the peopling
someone through a bathroom them not
knowing there's no exchange of service
there is there so there's even less
there's even less of a reason for it to
be rough
I see what's another what's an example
of something that's more morally on the
boundary compromise at the people in
what is pretty morally or that's not
touch osc you know what why is that why
is there a line between the fact that
this
no touch I would say this there's books
called ethics of touch okay so does that
proposal as well you sort of the guy
saying like why is it that certain body
parts are sanctioned and certain ones
are not yeah so I do find that I find
that really interesting I you can pay
someone to rub your head the night not
your little head and that's well one of
a man's chest but not woman's chest yeah
it's just these weird kind of boundaries
that exist which is almost because
they're nervous it's a narrative that we
attach to particular areas isn't it
that's one interesting first like in
some cultures even seeing parts of a
body is well this is not allowed and
Victorians used to cover piano legs with
fabric worthy yeah which is insane what
was the thing you asked before people
think they know the others good skirt
that's it
so we would do a form of the people
thing I would but I would as well but
like you have no idea talking I wouldn't
have a major problem with it but it's it
it's different because it's it's a
violation that wasn't like okay so if
you if you pay someone to rub you and
they enjoy it yeah that's partly this
was part of the contract although there
isn't it there was a reasonable
expectation of how much enjoyment they
will get from it or the tolerance of how
much an enjoyment or enjoyment and
you're like well it can exist within
that range but if it overshoots that way
more than you bargained for
yeah then that's why do you feel a bit
like oh no that's a bit odd because I
was only expecting completely stepped
out of the paradigm that is the
transactional relationship that you'd
already entered into okay they're going
the toilet you don't expect anyone's
watching it at all that's outside of the
paradigm what about like guys perving it
women as they walk down the street
because that's like a step away from so
that's similar to like I'll give you a
ten pound note not realizing you really
like ten pound notes like not just like
the average or a great tempo tenant yeah
but that's not I'm fine with that
because
last time got it I for me I think as
long as I am aware of it because like as
long as he's not gonna like film it but
on YouTube I suppose once you're aware
of it then it's uncomfortable because
you know I know that we're running out
of a book there's a thought I firm
that's just come to mind and I want to
give it to you to guys so I recently
chatted to a woman who goes on loose
women quite regularly okay and she
reminded me of a discussion that had
gone on there and they said do you think
that liking other girls photos on
Instagram is cheating okay and she said
yes she said yes that is a man putting
himself out there and identifying
himself and giving a I like highlighting
himself to other women and drawing
attention to himself and liking their
photos and was like she's making
assumptions about his attention yeah yep
but I wasn't what do we think of that
the analogy that I drew was would you
say that a man looking other women as
they walk past in a nightclub is
cheating hmm and there was a there's a
line somewhere along that where it
becomes okay so is it when they say
something to them mmm because what it
actually is if you want to draw the line
somewhere in sort of flirtation or
talking is not actually in the act
because the act is just a manifestation
of the intention the intention if the
intention was I want to pull that woman
even if you come up and eat and you just
you just poop on a exactly so this is
that this is the thing right so if you
just look at a woman across the other
side of the room and your intention is
that she'll look back at you and you're
dreaming that that woman is gonna come
over and kiss you and then you're gonna
take a home in that situation looking at
her is cheating yeah so this is the
different if you take the two extremes
that has the full experiment so one of
them has you
like hey how's it going but actually
they're really attracted to you and
because you're starting quite close to
them they get a bit of sexual tension
and and all of that but actually in your
head you were just like I want to ask at
the time or I don't know what where she
got her address from because I want to
buy my wife the same dress yeah as
opposed to you go over and then you I
you fart and the other do you like bread
and then you and then you fall over and
head butter and then you walk away like
oh but actually the whole intention was
I want to try and take it home or even
when you do less and you just look or
you don't even look you just sit nearer
don't look at all because this the
problem is like that
there's no binary and they solve it if
we just look at the action rather than
than the intention which is this woman's
claim of a paradigm then we are saying
that we have to set our own reasonable
point where we say that option is
acceptable and not acceptable and when
we get into that continuum we start to
get into the extreme insecurities that
lead to the like people making their
women cover up or out of pure insecurity
for other men looking at them and it
also goes to the if you to flip is like
by having a nice haircut and wearing out
clothes you are somehow putting yourself
out there for signalling yet by going to
the gym and making yourself look better
this looks like yeah oh no I do it for
me well I will but if you're judging it
by the action and not the intention then
you could construe anything to be
cheating
such an interesting little experiment
that I think about where the line for
cheating actually begins and ends I
think it's more about what are you gonna
because it kind of doesn't really matter
like if looking at someone is cheating
like does that mean that the
relationship does I mean you have to go
home and tell your wife like exactly
don't I have to go home and tell my wife
I liked another woman
because like I'm sure a lot of guys have
that are in those such situations all
the time in my clips and have a fella
exact thought and there are many
girlfriends that would want to know that
you look to another and then probably a
lot of women in the in exactly the same
situation on the opposite likewise not
reserving to me you wear or you could be
like it will be Marcus and men like
having sex with other women isn't
cheating yeah because the amorous isn't
I suppose you don't cheapen polyamorous
relationship possible she's like what is
cheating it's like breaking the
understanding of the situation that
you're in a lot of relationships don't
have that understanding to find all
right no one gets into a relationship
where is it okay for me
cheating is this so you could get into a
relationship with the woman who's
incredibly liberal and say well no you
can go out for dinner with
ex-girlfriends that's absolutely fine I
see like the the line for cheating can
be drawn with I think for most people
kissing yeah and and any sort of
physical stuff what about heavy petting
but gin something like what about
hand-holding what about washing past
someone in the line like for the water
cooler or was then it becomes more
difficult to justify a clean intention
if you were like holding hands wait like
even though it's not like it's not
technically cheating because of the
option but actually like why would you
be holding hands with her so probably
just it's just whatever it whenever
you're doing something that you wouldn't
do with a friend
well whatever it takes okay so you're
holding hands and you're holding onto
the sister as you cross the street
holding up to the Imam as you cross the
street I think it comes back to
intention so that was the metric that
they used when is it ariana grande when
this this guy at the funeral did you see
what happened no we're like it was a
pasta at a funeral and he he had Ariana
Grande from MIT John he's actually too
wide to do this is totally new but he he
hardly had his own facilities but he had
his arm Rhonda but he was grabbing a
boob and he was like edging his fingers
forward like that right yeah which was
very a Miss on camera and some people
were saying this is worse than any
normal sexual assault because he's like
he's like signaling like look what I can
do to you between my position of power
in front of all these cameras and still
get away with this is quite insidious
but the the metric people were using was
like because he was are not just being
friendly and so the responses were like
we
wouldn't touch your mom like that so hmm
which is hardest justify that it is
we've ended up quite a nice quite an
interesting topic that actually maybe I
should do that maybe we should do I
think that we should get shaping what I
want if you can't just accept facts even
will never be wealthy let's talk we do
Anton 101 Anton Anton I want on the park
and saw no one we scratched the surface
of life fails there we've got if you'd
like to send us in some of yours please
email the email addresses in the show
notes below what have we got coming up
soon what we got relationships 102 yep
what was the other one that you
suggested today honesty as a superpower
okay strength training you've wanted to
do for absolutely ages
I'll get strong it is a lie yeah what
else do we have in there out finances so
we're gonna go up these four amounts
personal finances and wealth management
and stuff like that but yeah please make
sure that you subscribe below video guy
team will make appear here and here and
here and here
just like Fanta yeah I'm on Yousaf said
in its gonna remove all we make the work
hard 15 anyway thank you very much for
tuning in we'll catch you next time okay
bye the layin
[Music]
you